warning this video contains cold B ah
spoilers all the spoilers all of them
what is up everybody its Anna Mac here
for anime uproar and welcome to a brand
new code geass video I'm really excited
about this video guys because we might
have actually found a clue from way back
in 2009 that appears to show a scene
from r3 from Code Geass season 3 this
discovery actually came through our
discord server where one of our active
members phantom black came across this
image and shared it with the rest of us
after that we all got to researching
together and we managed to find a whole
bunch of information on this image and I
want to thank shinkiro Gina Weinberg Bo
and soul maka for helping out with this
as well if you want to be a part of
these discussions in the future be sure
to join our discord server the link is
in the description and if you want to
stay up to date on all the latest code
geass season 3 news be sure to subscribe
and be sure to click that notification
bell so you can be the first to know
so yesterday in our discord server
phantom black brought my attention to
this image which shows Lelouch playing
with a dog that appears to be a collie
this image might look like a normal
promotional image at first until you
realize that you can see c2 and cheese
[ __ ] in the background and seem to is
wearing the same clothes she was wearing
in the final scene of r2 she also has
the same large red hat with a white
flower from the final scene not to be
confused with the small red hat that she
wears at other times in the anime in
fact if you look at what Lelouch is
wearing in this image he appears to be
wearing the same grey pants and long
colored white undershirt that the cart
driver is wearing in the final scene of
r2 not to mention the de scenery with
all the nature and sheep seems to be
very revealing as well because it looks
a lot like the scenery in the final
scene of r2 the scenery also gives us
some clues about their location because
clearly they're not in the tropical
region they're not in the desert they're
not in a jungle but they could still be
in England they could be in Switzerland
or maybe even New Zealand or Australia
after all wouldn't Australia be the
perfect place for Lelouch to hide we
know that it is marked as separate on
every single map in the world of Code
Geass we also know that in episode
fifteen of the first season of koteas
when Mao tries to abduct c2 he tells her
that he will take her to Australia again
implying that Australia is a great place
to hide in the world of code geass we
can also see Lelouch wearing a cross
around his neck in this image which is
strong symbolism Lelouch has often been
compared to a christ-like figure because
he died for our sins or for the sins of
the world and for his own sense unlike
Christ of course and then is resurrected
when we realized that he wasn't dead but
that he did not die at the end of our -
so again this symbolism might hint at
his resurrection or revival as we did
more research on this image you found
this a graphic in which someone has
already pointed out the clues in the
image that we just mentioned but also
look at this particular image itself it
is on a paper that has creases and the
glare so it is clear that this image is
actually a poster as I looked into it
further I also found this a Chinese
animation magazine cover that shows the
same image but only partially without
situ in the background this leads me to
conclude that this particular animation
magazine probably contained the full
image as a poster on the inside I then
ran a reverse image search for this
image and I was able to trace it all the
way back to August of 2009 on a Chinese
website
we know that our to finished airing in
September of 2008 which means that this
image can be traced back to less than a
year after our to finished airing as I
looked through the reverse image search
I also came across an altered version of
the same image which shows si tu dressed
in the same way in the foreground with
Lelouch and the Kali on the right and a
cabin in the background I was not able
to find a direct link for the second
image anywhere it appears to have
disappeared from the internet however
again it seems to show clearly a scene
from season 3 a scene in which Lelouch
and c2 are living together and hiding
away somewhere in the wilderness it is
also worth noting that the scenery in
this image seems very
alert to the scenery in the PV or teaser
trailer for the sequel in which Sousa
who is seen running away from something
on top of that I already mentioned that
this scenery is very similar to the
final scenes of r2 in which we see c2
riding in the cart and it is also
similar to the scene we see right before
that and that is Anya and orange picking
oranges at an orange farm and did you
know that there is an area in southern
Australia along the Murray River known
for both growing oranges and having lots
of sheep in fact in this 2012 article we
see that a record harvest of oranges in
this area led to a whole bunch of
leftover oranges being eaten by sheep so
is this a coincidence or is this the
perfect place for Lelouch to hide and is
it possible that orange being a faithful
servant of the louche is living
somewhere close by so that he can
protect Lelouch in case something
happened furthermore could this mean
that the reason orange was shown being
attacked in the PV or the teaser trailer
for season 3 is because someone was
trying to find Lelouch and they have to
go through orange first so what do you
guys think is this really an official
image that shows us the Lelouch survived
way back in 2009 or do you think this is
just a really high-quality unofficial
image do you happen to have any more
information on this image have you seen
it before let me know in the comments
I'd love to hear from you and that's it
for this video guys thanks so much for
watching and thanks for all your support
lately the channel has been growing
quickly lately and that means a lot to
us but even more importantly than that
we've been creating an amazing community
of anime fans around this channel if you
want to be a part of our community and
if you want to be the first to know
about all the latest news about Code
Geass season 3 be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell and if you
want to keep the discussion going with
us on a daily basis you can join our
discord server the link is in the
description once again thank you to
phantom black for finding this image
first and he will be starting up a
youtube channel soon so I left a link to
his YouTube channel in the description
if you want to show him some love thanks
again everybody and until next time see
a space cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]